et je me sens pas très concerné par le
sexe en ce moment tu veux pas dire
t'allonger bouton soir c'est moi un tel
objet 75 c'est que c'est que c'est chez
que ray j'aimerais comprendre ça
commence à venir des chimiquement dans
la vie voyez quoi pas comme ça je ne
sais pas grand chose si tu fais
complètement folle moi c'est pareil je
vais très mal
ultime année c'est un ancien client que
les défendent et wet est accusé de quoi
stups
il ya rien de bon là dans ces cartes n'a
pas une petite éclaircie l éthique et
attrape un couteau à dessert et que tu a
planté un coup dans le ventre à 100 mais
nord est c'est fait ça tout seul quand
je suis revenu dans la salle des fêtes
c'est une malade elle de son côté dit
que vous l'avez arracher cette non et de
toute façon même si j'avais voulu
j'aurais pas pu parce que ne portait pas
que jeudi à la sortie de l'école belge
présent dit mais je te dis que je
cherchais un baby sitter ou doit-on ton
ton jaune à mon père ya de plus de parts
ok tu sors ce soir non j'ai rendez vous
avec un mec dans ma chambre
d'accord mais je juge pas aidé à getafe
lundi c'est bon là je passais donc quand
je peux m'en méfie quand même tu connais
le blog de ton ex
comment est-ce que tu peux révéler des
choses que je t'ai confié sur mes
clients c'est quand même ironique quand
on désigne comme l'appui du barreau
alors que je suis en plaindrons sexuelle
parce qu'un témoin aurait pu vous
apercevoir n'ont pas de témoins humain
mais jacques son chien j'ai l'impression
que de toucher le fond j'ai constaté
dans le fond du fond arrive pas tout
de fer vale ton arrogance de petites
[ __ ] du 7e saloperie de sociopathes de
merde la réalité va exploser à la gueule
je n'ai malheureusement pas le temps de
continuer à lire ce recueil de poésie en
supprimant vos délires pervers je suis
épuisé je vais y aller non c'est parce
que tu crois en fait moi je garde les
enfants j aie est complètement stupide
tu trouves pas que ça marche bien chez
micron entre nous en fait j'ai peur de
toi te sens-tu drama normalement
développés qui accouchera couche toi
mais tu es gens sur les époux pour faire
circuler sans respirer calmement
alors est ce bien
ok c'est bon tu te sens mieux la voilà
c'était un fermier non mais enfin j'ai
aidé des types qui faisait débat d'après
en retrait du crack ou d'autres eu
besoin d'un fois une fuite voit la mer
vers le ciel c'est ton point de fuite
d'accord
cette fille complètement folle
moi c'est pareil je vais très très mal
merde mais mais tu as tout en mon nom
c'est différent là
toute dernière je suis mal bah ouais bah
non c'est un type que je connais moi
qu'est ce que vous faites là
bonsoir bonsoir je suis un cousin
éloigné du témoin en fait d'accord vous
êtes un ami c'est un ancien client que
les défendu par est accusée toi stups
stupéfiants et d'ailleurs je voulais
vous remercier de m'avoir sorti
d'affaires c'est fini là je dis plus la
bête a jamais eu la tête d'un dealer de
toute façon c'est qu'aujourd'hui ça oui
c'est gentil c'est vrai